welcome to this video playing the DRA
hot chick something like that and see
this is Slovakia ok again going for the
modern defense but ok well a six is a
little bit strong for me here so I'm
going for this line ok if I this is a
very sharp approach to this to this
opening I know that 97 h 4 is a very
core tech stuff so I'm taking Oh
interesting check yeah a possible 95
looks looks tricky of course hmm yeah
but I can give this check blast right
check go from there why should the night
go to d5 for the trade or somewhere else
for more counterclaim Nigeria King it to
not yeah I don't really know this not
very familiar with this but those
positions so I have to sort of make it
up long as we go Bishop to f5 to yeah
maybe to activate this one problem is is
always my my bishop on g7 here it is
just looking at this pawn on e5 and he's
not doing very much I really would love
to play e6 and Bishop f8 get it into
play or play f6 some time to to break up
this this pawn chain at first I want to
do this said trying to get rid of his
bishop
I'm not sure what Bishop c4 maybe is
doing maybe this was interesting okay
well knight c6 year was my idea yeah it
looks like we might get to an end game
quickly own is doing this okay I'm
probably here for up to eight calf
people trade route 7 it's not very
exciting let's see what can I do in this
end game is there some way forward TM f
6 for example f6e six yeah I want to
play a six but I don't want f 66 to
happen okay going for before here on
yeah okay i will play have six anyway
have to get this Bishop into play
there's no way around that um okay mm my
Play yeah he might play before sometime
I wonder before I he's playing this very
quickly I can go be 5 mm yeah probably
be five but it's not so good yes that my
king is not yet in the game but I have
to prevent some things in some things
here first okay king of seven he can
play a form yeah true not not so great
actually not so great there anyway I
have to get the King into the game so
Jim
don't I don't like to take that but I
really don't see what else bishops III
mmmm yeah it's not g5 not very
attractive this position and data on one
minute 24 my king is not playing ever
had it on let's say d7 I wouldn't mind
that so much here why this really better
night you know my maybe night yvonne d3
to see five okay so it's a playing it
simple not very ambitious Lee may be why
am I were looking things yeah might just
take with the king and approach yeah
possible yeah 97 if I go night is 7 i'm
not sure how to ever ever get the king
near the action night a seven blunders
the night time wasn't even worse night
be a tas bishop or not good Bishop t for
now is a good move check this is maybe
also a good move takes takes h5 the
bishop down not much that I can do here
I really have no alternative maybe the
king and porn endgame is just a win
possible white is very active now you
can just take em plaquing this is six
and when I think I think this should be
a win
mmm
you can just take rent check Jerry this
was just really bad right ok black
resigned yeah this this kind of position
wasn't very attractive but where exactly
did I spoil this I mean this is this is
definitely ok for like never I shouldn't
really lose but what did I do wrong yeah
I probably be five was too ambitious
right this was probably too bad i mean
it is yeah yeah i was too ambitious
there I should just play something
normal king of seven or so this is
helping him really with a form can still
amazing that yeah maybe age 6 I wanted
to play Bishop c3 at some point but not
really great maybe just hear you yeah I
am this is much much better this is of
course much much better yeah it's quite
simple if he does that I need to play
king g 7i have need to have this
available and this is just equal right I
mean this is very little pawns left just
four pawns and there's no way for white
for attendance position yeah this is
what I need to do well be five is making
my life very easy so we shouldn't play
that it can we can play whatever like
Age 3 or something and it's still a
little bit better this b5 idea wasn't
wasn't really great iam I should just
play king of seven or something you know
it's not a very comfortable position
that the problem is a little bit that I
am not totally I don't know their
opening yeah and
I I know that the most principled way to
play is 97 then there's h4 c 5 h 5 this
kind of super crazy line that i really
don't want to play it that without
knowing it and the chest this is why i
went for this simple solution but it's
just this end game is not very
comfortable here why this is just a bit
better I mean I don't think I should
lose it but I some jet moves really did
the trick ya hear hear he's really here
widest is really winning and that
definitely shouldn't take no I'm white
is not winning a half can do this
actually yeah i saw that i am I saw too
late that the king and porn endgame is
winning and losing from from my
perspective oh now it's actually a draw
okay yeah I had this ahead to add some
doubt here I have to play age three now
27 seconds I have to play age 3 m and
this is a drop you can defend this they
cannot go all the way over I can do they
get here this is a drawing so we had
spoiled it actually with with g3 he has
to play h4 and win with this reserve
length on this I mean everything else
failing what can just go back and pick
up the pond I have a stupid yeah could
have still drawn this still drawing this
yeah but maybe I resigned a little bit
too much at least I thought that its
loss and I didn't really pay that much
attention anymore Wow not a good game
thanks for watching still